hi guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to nle
choppa
final warning before i start do not
forget to like
comment and subscribe especially
subscribe my next milestone is 15 000
followers and each and every one of you
helps i said followers i meant
subscribers the reason i said followers
is because
i want you guys to remember to follow me
on instagram all of these submissions
are literally from my instagram people
either dm them to me
or they submit them like through polls
and stuff on my instagram so don't
forget
follow my instagram it's in the bio okay
let me
start
this okay
god damn crispy like krispy kreme
okay
[Music]
the performance don't inform me about
who informing that show final one
76 to stay like a bumble bee
couple couple thoughts i already have
this is not a covid safe
music video i'd like to say that number
one number two
we got a lot of friends like he seems to
be very popular
like he's got you know from there friend
there friend there
and they all seem to be carrying guns
like do you got a gun store near you
how did you all get these guns um
last thought
what is the guy that owns this gas
station thinking
is he there does he know or did they
just pull up and start shooting
but they ain't never make it back to
them
rap but never mention two weeks we put
you where the news that i bet his family
slide by myself before i call a [ __ ] my
fingernails dirty cause i'm still a gray
digger
and we ain't camping on wax if we never
put the trigger and goon steady putting
jimmy glow up in his whistle
okay so he said his fingernails are
dirty because he's a gravedigger
i want to say that means that he like
kills people because he's had a couple
other references
to like shooting people so let me know
in the comments
is that what he meant i think that's
what he meant never been the one to say
today i'm the one clenching on the drake
make sure he don't get away or i'm the
only thing i chase in the full race the
back of his neck hit the ground to decay
walk up to one secret stood over put one
in his face
better stay up in the house like the
[ __ ] from that so raven catch that
[ __ ] walking now we in the bushes
never seen a threat on the internet just
to prove a point that this and don't get
into that we leaving it to the
performance don't inform me about who
informing that
final one
okay i think he is talking about warning
like his opposition or like maybe some
like
people he's got beef with that this is
your final warning
if you keep acting the way you're acting
there will be violence
i'll do it that's what i think he's
saying i also want to say that one guy
has a fire orange jumpsuit
i like it they ain't never make it back
he died but never mentioned
okay so he said that the police can lick
his
nuts and suck his wood
one just statistically speaking
that means he must be a little
gay you know like he probably likes guys
a little bit
like just statistically unless it's a
female officer but just
odds are it'll probably be a guy second
thing that's not a good thing to say to
the police what if you go to trial they
could just play that
this is good i'm throwing donuts in the
air
i love donuts i like that part of the
sauce
[Music]
better pray for my enemies life can't
give me limits so i start clutching
[Music]
family oh max that's terrible
i put him on the news i bet his family
viewed that
you don't feel a little bad
like that's his family you know that's
that's not a nice thing to say i didn't
like this song
three out of ten three out of ten i said
it
you guys can disagree with me all you
want in the comments
but i said it and i meant it three out
of ten
but let me know what video i should
react to next time do not forget to like
comment and subscribe i'll talk to you
guys
probably soon probably really soon